- You have to live humbly
to get what you want.
- Okay.
- The biggest problem
for people going for it
is while they're building
their fitness brand
they're not willing to
live with four roommates
or work at Checkers.
- Got it.
- Got it?
- Okay.
- You can't have both.
Because, if you're gonna go
for it, and you don't have
the money coming in right away,
you have to live.
- Right.
- People think that they get to stay
living the same lifestyle they have
when they have another job, you don't.
When you go for it, you gotta
take a step back in your
day-to-day, for your future.
People don't have the humility
to work at Burger King
while they're getting theirs.
(upbeat music)
- The (bleep) thing is
extremely interesting to me,
especially off the last 2
meetings I had with (bleep)
Its gonna happen.
- Wait I hug.
- I hug too.
How are you?
- so Nice to meet you.
- We launched June, 1st.
- Of this year?
- Yeah, we just launched.
And seventeen days later Hoda
Kotb went on the Today Show
and called it her favorite thing.
- Fuck you.
- Yeah we've been doing great,
but how do you keep the momentum going?
- You continue to market well.
- Okay, I don't know how to do that
and there where I'm stuck.
- You take the clip of Hoda
and you run on Facebook to 40
to 60-year-olds in perpetuity.
Let me tell you something.
I believe the communication of something.
Is equally as important as
the quality of something.
- Of course.
- The best product in the world
not communicated well doesn't sell.
- That's right.
- The shittest product in the world
communicated perfectly by
me will not work either.
So, I just think that you
can't get to your ambitions
without being a perfect
executioner in 2019 COMs.
Hoda on the Today Show.
Instagram swipe ups.
- We have QVC also in January.
- All of it great.
You understand?
- Yes
(upbeat beat)
- I was just thinking
Instagram live for 5 minutes a day.
Because it will give the normal
shout out on their thing.
You can do it on the road.
- We figured out the most
subtle thing which was
just the nuances of my face.
Even though I'm saying the same stuff.
Has made people like me more
because when I'm talking to everybody,
it's a faceless human.
And it comes off more aggressive because
there is no human in front of me.
But when I'm talking one
on one, there's a subtle
Isn't that interesting Ant?
Me and drock were talking
about this for 10 minutes.
Nonetheless, alright
back it out where good.
Should I make videos for them?
Did the way Sam designed it
because my videos will sell better.
- We can do videos.
- Thank you, Economy did
better than Crush it.
Because the difference
was in the little offers
of 25, there was a little video.
Should I make them real quick?
- Yeah
- Okay cool, ready?
So for the 35 sneaker boarder deal.
I'm doing a 5 minute
Instagram live with you.
(upbeat music)
Can I tell you something that
I would love to challenge you
to sleep on?
Because it's a very touchy issue.
That I think that you
can help so many people.
- I have no problem with issues.
- I know you don't, I'm talking macro.
- Oh okay.
- The fact that you navigated to the level
you navigated as a minority female.
You can help so many 23-year-olds
understand the context difference.
Of what you went through
versus what's happening now.
And not in the "I had harder than you."
- Right
but you did.
- Yes
And if you can make it not feel like
"I had harder than you."
and you can make it here
is your opportunity.
That I am envious of.
And by the way,
right now where race relations
are in America is in a high.
So what that makes a 21-year-old feel
is its harder than ever
yet, I have a funny feeling
you know it is not harder than ever.
- It is not.
I know.
- I go there as a 42-year-old white dude.
So you know how scary that is?
I go on Breakfast Club and
like "It's easier than ever"
and I'm like fucking Jesus
I'm going to get destroyed.
I'm a fucking 42-year-old white dude.
- (laughs loudly)
- But, for you to say it
you have so much more air cover than I do.
And you would help them so much because
they would believe you
more than they believe me.
- I have heard that.
- They would say "Easy for
you white dude fuck you."
but they can't do that to
you, and you could help them.
Think about what do you
have to do to be successful?
I think people like us.
I think in history people look
back at what I figured out
as a really important moment which is.
It is remarkable that I don't
spend any time being Gary Vee.
I figured my model which was following me
your not going to be able to do that.
If you take 15 to 20 minutes
and whether we help
with that infrastructure
or you get an intern,
million different things.
Let me tell you how easy it could be.
If you text, I'm gonna just use him Sal.
And be like "this week I wanna
talk about cryptocurrency."
if Sal shows up downstairs
at the bar of your building
or at the Starbucks.
And that 15 minutes is
Sal asking you 4 questions
and you answer them.
And then that is a Linkedin post.
The next day in first
person Sal writing it
That is what I have done.
I run a 900 person company.
What I'm doing is, I'm
filming this right now.
This meta moment might be.
How a busy executive needs just 15 minutes
to be in the content game.
- Got it.
- This right here is how I figured it out.
Originally it was the Ask Garyvee Show
where I did have to sit down for a hour
and interview Hanna and her
6th year at Vayner Media.
Now I've gone much
further down to Daily Vee
where I'm just being filmed.
Because I don't even
have that fucking hour
to do that YouTube show.
Then I did that for 3
years. And all of a sudden
I'm like "that content
getting stale" and weirdly
in the last month I'm back
to doing a little bit of
Ask Garyvee. I'm fighting for that hour
But the key is
how do you not destruct yourself?
But you need to have
something that's a pillar.
(upbeat music)
- Literally I know what I
want to do with my life.
I'm a filmmaker
I'm a storyteller, and literally
all these guys can relate
so much they know I care.
When I arrived to New York
one of my first jobs was for Casey.
I used to work for Casey.
And now I found this opportunity here.
I'm almost two years here.
I've been little by little
growing and improving myself,
within the Darb advertising industry.
Creative and stuff like that.
- So I understand everything.
What can I help with?
You want advice?
- I want advice.
I look up to you so much.
- Thank you.
- I want advice and I wanna see
if I'm going in the right direction.
- You're definitely going
in the right direction
let me explain why.
My ability to get you a job
with the biggest directors
in the world is very high.
And the longer you stay and do great work
the more leverage you have with me.
So if you want to leave right now?
I probably will introduce
you to some people.
And by the way I would.
If you literally said "Today
is my last day" I know your not
and I want to go to Hollywood
I would literally
introduce you to 5 people.
- Appreciate it.
- And if you go crush Mayo
and work for another year
and then a year from now you
do that, I gonna try harder.
- Thank you Gary.
- You're welcome my friend.
- Thank you for the meeting.
How you doing? You excited?
- I'm really excited.
- Good
- It's definitely one of those
things that you're nervous
- Yeah of course.
- I'm just quitting with
no real next income plan.
- Do you have some
savings? You'll be okay?
- Oh yeah
I got it all mapped
out think of budgeting.
I know takes 6 months to invest
in learning the platform.
There's literally a whole other dimension
your working in when you're in VR.
- Your preaching brother.
Listen I have tons of
relationships that (bleep)
and there doing a lot of
interesting shit in that space.
A lot people "Yes me" in this meeting.
And then don't take me up on
it and then I see them 3 years
later and then there like "Why
didn't I take you up on it".
I think it's a level of a mixed between
cynicism, or pride, or a
million different reasons why
somebody would not take me up on it.
- It is a little intimidating I'm sure.
- Correct but I'm desperate
for you to understand
how much I appreciate the
value you brought here.
And how much I want to
return that and so I'm here.
Brother thank you so so much.
I can't wait to see you again.
- Let me get a selfie.
- Yes sir. I'm glad you asked.
- Can you speak to how you
invest in Vayner Media employees
that are moving on to a new job.
- Yeah it's a good point.
Honestly if you're going to
decide to narrate it this way.
Even use your voice right now in here.
Because I want all of you to always know
how this all gets post edited.
Which is I'm out of the equation.
Give me a look.
I'm playing for life here.
When you play for admiration and legacy
you don't begrudge when a employee
is leaving for whatever reason.
You've seen what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to put them on.
I want people to say to their grandkids
that "Oh I left that guy Gary Vee on TV."
Or whatever the fuck TV is in 100 years.
Yeah let me tell you a story
I worked for his company.
You worked for his company?
Yeah and when I was leaving it.
Instead of being a dick like
most people he helped me.
Do you know why I ever
got into that VR company.
It was because Garyvee did that.
That's nice, that's
legacy, that's admiration.
I will never understand how
people run their companies.
With their selfish interest in mind.
My selfish interest in mind
is to be selfless which
then leads to admiration.
Listen I had a very interesting
epiphany with myself
the last 100 days I'm like
"oh shit its admiration".
I'm like "oh shit its admiration".
Its really locked in.
Legacy was a way of saying that,
but admiration is the short
term thing that I can see.
Can you show these faces?
They just walk in and they got requests.
My life about requests.
You know what I am
I'm like a fucking show pony.
There like 'pony do this pony do that'
Okay
What would you like me to do sir?
- Talking about how you
moved the Vayner experience.
From a Facebook page, to posting it
on Instagram and all the other sites.
- Okay got it, ready?
- Thank you.
- Thank you sir.
Hey everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is Pod Sessions.
Pretty much my favorite
pillar type that I've created
in the last year or two.
But I don't get to do often because
First, I like mixing up the guests I have.
The format if your listening
or watching for the first time
is three guests and I.
And we just kind of shoot the shit.
Talk about different stuff.
People that I have context for.
Either I'm watching very
carefully from afar or actually
know. All 3 here I actually
know pretty well 2 I've met.
My guy.
- My guy.
- I've been looking forward to this.
How are you?
- Good
- Great to you see again
man, how have you been?
- Great
- Sit sit
Fame and money doesn't change you.
Fame and money takes
the energy out of you.
Its takes the hunger out of you.
When your hungry and nobody
is feeding you but then
you get a big fucking 18
burgers and you eat them all.
I'm always suppressing the
good that everybody is chasing
because it keeps me hungry a fuck.
Let me give you the most librating thing
that I can ever tell an artist or somebody
trying to make something happen.
If your good enough its gonna happen.
- I believe that.
- I believe in that the most.
All the people that are now
53 and they thought they
were good enough they weren't.
It wasn't that they
picked the wrong manger.
It wasn't that the
gatekeepers stopped them.
They weren't good enough.
Especially now my guy what gatekeeper?
Keep putting shit on
SoundCloud and Spotify.
- Yeah
- Are you kidding me?
Fucking 20 years ago Killy had no shot.
There were gatekeepers,
there's no fucking gatekeepers.
Instagram, YouTube,
Spotify, and SoundCloud
that's the gatekeeper. And guess what?
Even if you run rap caveat
your not the gatekeeper.
Your a mini mini mini gatekeeper.
How does shit show up on rap caviar?
Not that, shits happened then they pick.
But you got to get to
that that first step.
Love your fans unconditionally.
Put out music that's in your fucking soul.
Shit will happen.
'Gary Vee you tell all the
rappers the same advice'
because its the fucking truth dick.
(laughs)
No shit I'm telling them
the same shit motherfuckers
I know what your thinking.
This the same shit, exactly.
- Facts
- Yeah its the truth.
- Its the truth.
Get used to it.
Listen I'll give you
another piece of advice
and this is advice I give everybody.
You fuck with somebody in sports
'she's cute.' 'there funny.'
DM and be like yo I fuck with you.
Because you never know when there like
'I love killamonjaro.'
that's fucking fire I'm
gonna put that on my blog.
Give love, everyone trying to act cool.
I want to create a blog post.
Where people can download 4
or 5 different audio clips
that I just recorded and make them
there alarm when they wake up.
I wanna completely takeover
the phone alarm game.
In the same way my back drop
is on a ton of people's screens.
I think my alarm is going to dominate.
So A let's figure out the function of
if you have an android or an Iphone.
Its going to be an blog post
How to take the alarm.
In there a step by step of how to do that.
We need to make that.
He's got the files on
that camera right now.
And that is what Calvin is probably
texting a team about right now.
If he's washing his hands
in the bathroom because
I told him that's were I
came up with it just now.
That's it. I like that
to come out next week.
- Sonic branding.
- What's that?
- Its like the best thing going.
- Happy birthday my guy.
Man I really think its
gonna happen for you.
- Thanks man.
- I like hit him up and I was like 'yo'
There's somebody I really
want you to look at.
I really really feel it.
I also think you're saying something.
I like the way you're painting
pictures of your reality.
For me its how it comes through my head.
Actually I never said this to you.
You've heard me talk about it.
Do I feel like I'm there?
Do I not feel like I'm there.
And that's basically how I judge.
Do I feel like I'm rolling
with the 2 of you through in Atalanta.
Or do I not. Do I think I'm
watching you roll through.
And when I feel like I'm in there
That's when its gets my attention.
- Man that's dope.
- That's actually the answer
of why I fuck with you.
Wanting it to happen in 6 years
instead of 1 is how its
actually happens in 1.
Wanting it to happen in 1.
Is why 99% of people lose.
I believe in that the most.
(upbeat music)
I was always this happy my whole life.
Because I was raised in a environment and
I had the DNA,
that just did not allow
judgment to be apart of you.
That's it.
And that's why I'm trying
to get everybody else
to eliminate judgment.
That's why I want you and him
to never ever ever care about
what anybody else thinks
because it is game over,
game over, game over.
I'm unbeatable, I'm 100%
unbeatable for the rest of my life.
I am. Because even I lose by
your standard I can't hear you.
If I lose it all.
Next thing that goes through
my mind is I can't wait
to stick it to everybody when I come back.
And take all those social media comments
and when I come back.
I gonna make a 10 hour video and be like
'let me tell you what the world
said about me 6 years ago'
When I lost it all.
(upbeat music)